so uh you know we live in a very scary
time where our private information is
constantly being stolen and leaked to
the world so i'm doing my best to get
ahead of that phenomenon by having
people come on the show who know me and
reveal secrets about me in a segment we
call
petey leaks
hpd weeks
and once again here's my friend and
mentor conan o'brien everybody going
so i i can't stress this enough i
sincerely have no idea what conan is
about to say
and what i'm about to say is absolutely
true uh
ladies and gentlemen uh some of you may
think i'm going to tell an embarrassing
story about pete or talk about some
crazy dark admission that he shared with
me but i'm not going to do that okay i'm
going to keep this short and sweet and
this is absolutely true
pete has a concave chest
show this this is you may think kev
there it is
i noticed
i noticed this once when he didn't have
his shirt on that his chest goes in when
it's supposed to go out
and other than everything else about him
is perfectly normal but it goes in this
way where there's no room for a heart or
lung
there isn't
now
uh okay less room for internal organs
but
pete's chest does has many wonderful
uses here are two of my favorites
take a look you can use it when you want
to enjoy your favorite salsa that's
fantastic
it's right there
yeah
and here are some tourists riding
donkeys into the pale canyon
of pete's chest
that's just a true story it goes i don't
know
absolutely true
true
what yes
true that's not true
absolutely true we'll listen as an
executive producer we'll get this all
fixed this will be
by season three we'll have built this
all up but
but what will fix this
for a late night host there's no fixing
this